[Música]
y tal como se esperaba el presidente
Guillermo lasso declaró la muerte
Cruzada y disolvió la asamblea nacional
justo cuando estaba a punto de empezar
la segunda jornada del juicio político
en su contra para hablar de este tema
saludamos en Quito a Fernando Carrión al
es analista político y académico de
flacso Ecuador señor Carrión Bienvenido
a France 24 Esta es una medida sin
precedentes en la historia de Ecuador
Buenos días Andrés un saludo cordial a
toda la audiencia Sí esta esta figura de
la muerte Cruzada nació en el año 2008
cuando se aprobó esta Constitución que
en aquel momento la presidía el
presidente Correa y fue el que propuso
esta esta esta idea de aquella época
para acá siempre ha aparecido la muerte
Cruzada más bien como un mecanismo de
negociación y hoy día es la primera vez
que se ejecuta de forma explícita ahora
qué va a pasar a partir de este momento
Cuál es el proceso para que se pueda
aplicar esta llamada muerte Cruzada
bueno en el mismo decreto que el que el
presidente de la república ha firmado el
día de hoy y le ha presentado a la
sociedad ecuatoriana se establece siete
días para que el Consejo Nacional
electoral convoque elecciones que tienen
que ser elecciones para la asamblea
porque se ha disuelto la asamblea y
tiene que volver a recomponerse y para
presidente de la república que tendría
que ejecutarse en un lapso de 30 de de
90 días máximo la las elecciones y luego
vendrá el proceso de de sucesión tanto
de la presidencia como de la asamblea y
eso ocurrirá más o menos hasta hasta fin
de año y las nuevas autoridades tanto de
la asamblea como la de Presidencia
tendrán un tiempo de de acción no mayor
hasta el año 2025 en que se cierra el
período para el cual fue elegido tanto
los miembros de la asamblea cuanto el
presidente lazo a la República del
Ecuador ahora que usted menciona este
proceso electoral que se viene en el
Ecuador cree usted que este Tal vez es
una oportunidad de la oposición para la
oposición Mejor dicho tal vez para el
correísmo Para volver a retomar el poder
en Ecuador
si nosotros miramos el último proceso
electoral que vivimos el cinco de
febrero uno uno se da cuenta de un par
de cosas que son importantes primero el
correísmo fue la fuerza más votada en el
país pero sumando todos los votos de los
candidatos a las 221 alcaldías solo
logra el 23% y la fuerza que le sigue
que le sigue es pachacútec con el once
por ciento por qué es esto
principalmente porque tenemos un sistema
de representación política con 276
reparadores políticos probablemente el
Ecuador sea el país que más cantidad de
organizaciones políticas tenga por lo
menos por lo menos en América Latina y
ese es un poco el origen del problema
que hemos tenido en estos días porque el
presidente de la república llega a la
asamblea con doce asambleístas de 137 es
decir no llega ni siquiera con el 10% Y
eso le ha significado de alguna manera
gobernar con una oposición muy fuerte
dentro de la asamblea señor Carrión Qué
papel va a tener el ejército en toda
esta discusión en la aplicación de esta
muerte Cruzada por ejemplo hace unos
momentos acaban de decir que ellos
apoyan la constitución
Bueno yo creo que las fuerzas armadas y
la policía Ya están jugando este rato
porque prácticamente lo que han hecho es
cerrar la asamblea de tal manera de que
no se pronuncie porque hace pocos días
el presidente de la asamblea el doctor
shakisela había indicado que no van a
aceptar la muerte Cruzada porque es
ilegal unas declaraciones que no tienen
ningún fundamento pero que podría pues
invocarse y y y empezar a operar Pero
este rato la asamblea está cerrada por
qué porque están las fuerzas armadas y
está la policía ahí Y creo que eso va a
ser difícil y hasta incluso convocada
porque no se necesita siquiera que este
decreto que emitió el presidente de la
república hoy en la mañana sea publicado
por el registro oficial es decir ya está
este rato en vigencia significa entonces
que el ejército está apoyando a la
asamblea nacional
yo creo que no yo creo que está apoyando
más bien lo que ellos mismos son
sostenido la lógica de la de la
Constitución que en el artículo 148 de
la Constitución se establece las tres
causales por las cuales se puede hacer
esta declaratoria de muerte Cruzada y
las dos que ha invocado el presidente ni
siquiera requieren un pronunciamiento de
la corte constitucional la corte
constitucional simplemente tiene que
conocer por eso es que el presidente ha
enviado hoy de forma inmediata el
decreto que ha firmado el decreto 741
ahora qué dice esta medida sobre el
presidente sobre el mismo presidente
Guillermo lasso teniendo en cuenta que
esto es un contexto en el contexto en el
que se da por ejemplo hoy era la segunda
jornada se esperaba que se reanudara la
segunda sesión para continuar con este
proceso político en su contra
a mí me parece que el presidente de la
república tomó esta decisión el día
domingo y por qué tomó esa decisión el
día domingo porque se produjo la
elección del presidente y los dos
vicepresidentes de la asamblea además de
el consejo de administración de la
función legislativa el cal y en los dos
casos la votación fue muy alta
la asamblea tiene 137 asambleístas y la
presidencia de la asambleas se obtuvo
con 96 votos lo cual significa cuatro
votos más de los que requería el
presidente para para sostenerse y los
otros miembros de la asamblea incluso
con mayor votación entonces la impresión
que me da es que probablemente el
presidente lo que pensó son dos cosas La
una es que podía haber obtenido la
votación de los menos de 92 votos pero
iba a tener una asamblea legislativa
totalmente en contra que le impediría
funcionar le impediría gobernar y por
eso parece que finalmente tomó la
decisión de la muerte Cruzada para
resolver esa situación y ver qué es lo
que pasa en el proceso electoral que se
avecina en tres meses más o menos ahora
se había advertido ya sobre que el
presidente podría tomar esta medida y
que esto desencadenaría todo una
movilización en las calles entrará
aparte de una crisis política al Ecuador
en una crisis social tal vez
a mí me parece que eso es lo más
probable porque de alguna manera toda la
conflictividad que estaba manejando en
el en el país en el Ecuador era una
conflictividad interinstitucional en
este caso entre El Ejecutivo y el
legislativo eso que se conoce con el
nombre del conflicto entre poderes los
principales poderes pero este momento
desaparece eso Y creo que todo se va a
ir hacia la calle todo se va a ir hacia
las movilizaciones y aquí lo que vamos a
tener es una mezcla de movilizaciones
sociales con movilizaciones políticas
porque tendrán que aparecer los
candidatos y empezará también la campaña
electoral Espero que finalmente pues lo
que lo que predomines sea el proceso
político de las elecciones y no el
proceso político de la manifestación
pero me parece que eso es lo más
probable que ocurra
Fernando carrera una lista político y
académico de flacssocador Gracias por
atendernos hasta a último minuto porque
esta fue la noticia que no solo despertó
a Ecuador sino a toda la región en
América Latina no Muchísimas gracias a
ustedes un saludo cordial bien De esta
manera despedimos un tercer bloque de
directo América en France 24 sigan con
nosotros que ya regresamos con más
[Música]